- Hi. Oh, don't pee on me.
Hello, oh puppies.
(upbeat music) (barking)
Hey, I'm Demi Lovato and I'm hanging out
with some puppies while
answering your questions.
How am I supposed to
start answering questions?
Oh, you're so cute. Hello.
You're a boy, I just found that out.
I like the brown ones. They're playful.
Can you describe your new album,
Tell Me You Love Me, in three words?
No, no. (laughter)
My album in three words would be...
vulnerable, raw and
soulful. Here we go, nope.
Would you release a song
in Spanish in the future?
If so, which Latin artist would
you like to collaborate with?
I actually, oh those are my
pants, those are my pants.
No, honey. You will have to
wait and find out because I
recorded something recently
that I think you will like.
Oh my god. (laughter)
Why did you decide to name
your album Tell Me You Love Me?
I decided to name my
album Tell Me You Love Me
because it's one of my
favorite songs off of the album
and it also is a very
vulnerable and raw title.
Oh no, he peed on his face. (laughter)
You want bones? Bone? No?
How is this album different than
Confident or any of your other albums?
This album is different than my
other albums because it's more soulful,
and I think it's the most mature
out of all the albums that I've made.
And I've done a lot of
growing up personally
and professionally so I think
that that's the reason why.
Are you gonna help me read the question?
I recently just got out of
a long-term relationship.
I was wondering how you
deal with a breakup.
I deal with a breakup by
leaning on my closest friends
and by getting out into
the dating scene again.
I think that it's important
not to dwell on certain things
and just to get back
out there and have fun.
(laughter) Oh my god.
These are my pants and that's my finger.
And that's my next question. (laughter)
Are you planning on
directing... (laughter)
Are you planning on directing
more of your music videos
like how you directed Made in the USA?
I think I would love to
direct at some point,
but maybe the next one, who knows?
You've had such an amazing career so far.
What has been your best achievement?
I think having a number one single was
definitely a career highlight and
also getting my Grammy nomination.
(laughter) What's your
favorite tattoo that you have
and are you planning on getting more?
I'm not planning on getting more as of
right now, but that'll change I'm sure.
My favorite tattoo is my lion on the hand.
You're an inspiration to your fans and to
other people who have
gone through tough times.
What does it mean to you
to be able to inspire
and change the lives of
others through your fame?
I think that it's really important
that you use your platform for good
and if I've been able to
use my tough times and...
use them as...
There's puppies. I don't
know. There's puppies.
I think that if I'm able
to use the difficult times
that I've been through as
lessons for other people,
then I think I'm happy to inspire others.
Nope, those are my questions.
What song on your newest album
do you think is the most personal?
I think the most personal
song on this album is
either You Don't Do It For
Me Anymore or Ready For Ya.
I think Ready For Ya
is a song that I wrote
that explains a lot about a
breakup that I went through.
After watching your cover of Silent Night
I couldn't help but think would you ever
consider making a Christmas album.
I have considered making
a Christmas album.
Hopefully I'll do that
soon. You never know.
Social media can be really
tough on a person mentally.
Any tips on staying sane
and confident in a world
where every photo is
FaceTuned and Photoshopped?
Well, I think that
learning to love yourself
is very important and
in the skin that you're
in is very important.
It can be difficult at times and of course
the pressures are high
but I think that as long
as you love yourself
that's all that matters.
What's the most funniest, the
most funniest, memorable prank
you've ever pulled and
who did you pull it on?
The funniest prank that
I ever pulled on somebody
was I pulled a prank on my
security guard and in Vegas
it's legal to hire a lady of the night
to make surprise visits for somebody.
So I did that and...
I sent her to my security
guard's room and told her
to be very forceful and
make herself enter the room.
And she did just that
and he was very startled
and I'm glad that he didn't keep her.
Which song on this record was the
hardest to write slash record?
The hardest song to record
was Smoke and Mirrors,
which is on the deluxe
version of the album.
It was a very emotional
song that I wrote on,
that basically reminded me,
what are you doing back there?
That's my elbow. What are you doing?
That reminded me of...
some very emotional times
that I went through.
Do you want to act again?
I think I would love to act at some point,
I've just been so focused
with music right now
that I haven't had the chance to.
What has been your favorite
fan interaction or experience?
I haven't had a favorite fan experience
because all of them are so special.
I think that any time a fan tells me
that I've saved their life
is extremely meaningful and
it just matters so much to me and it's
kind of unfathomable, so
it really means a lot.
Last question. Who's the first person
you call when you have good news?
The first person I call is either
my mom or my best friend Marissa.
It's definitely my mom, actually.
And then I call Marissa.
But I tell them good news and
they get so excited for me
cause they're so supportive
and I love them so much.
Interviewing with puppies was so much fun.
They are so adorable. I wish
I could take all of them home.
But you actually can.
They are from North Shore
Animal League America and they're all up
for adoption so hashtag
get your rescue on.
So that's all I have. I'm
gonna go play with puppies now.
Because they're so adorable and
they're very, very playful right now.
Oh. Oh. Oh, so sweet.